presidential campaigns shifted back to
Iowa over the weekend gun control was
the number-one topic after the shootings
in El Paso and Dayton that as you know
killed 31 people more than 20 of the
2020 Democratic candidates offered their
solutions while talking to voters at the
Iowa State Fair Ed O'Keefe is there in
Des Moines with the latest on this story
so ed what was the reaction from the
voters to this well Gail good morning
welcome back voters here and across the
country
are generally supportive of expanding
the national gun background check system
and are open to other changes in gun
laws that's why Democratic contenders
spent the weekend talking about their
ideas to drive down gun violence I don't
think my own kids are gonna let it go
away these two tragedies have made
people feel something different gun
control was front and center for
Democratic candidates looking to
persuade voters at the Iowa State Fair
the latest CBS News battleground tracker
poll found that 55% of Democrats here in
Iowa
say they must hear a candidates position
on gun control policy in order to vote
for them Congress cannot have gun policy
written and dictated by the NRA on
Saturday 18 candidates participated in a
forum on how to reduce gun violence what
we lack is the United States Congress to
have the courage to act the gun industry
controls Washington a case a ours they
have no business in our neighborhoods in
peacetime in the United States of
America
my beautiful four-year-old daughter
Dayla was struck by a stray bullet March
2011 one mother's tragic personal story
brought candidate Andrew yang to tears I
have a six and three-year-old boy has
some imagine I'm so sorry President
Trump said Friday he's open to expanding
gun background checks
that word meaningful background check we
asked former Vice President Joe Biden
what that would mean to him
what would a meaningful background check
system look like to you it would be
universal background checks the period
Biden says in a New York Times op-ed
this morning that as president he would
work to renew the assault weapons ban
other Democratic contenders are in favor
of either a mandatory or voluntary
federal gun background or gun back
buyback program sorry New Jersey senator
Cory Booker says he supports licensing
every firearm in this country but
remember none of this happens unless
Democrats win the White House and full
control of Congress or find a way to
work with Republicans Anthony good point
at ed O'Keefe in a stormy Iowa thanks ed